Welcome to Genoa, a beautiful port city in
the north of Italy.
It's a very vertical city, built on a lot
of hills.
So many hills, in fact, that the city has
several funicular railways and elevators
tunnelled through the rock, shortcuts that
get around
miles of twisty, congested roads or thousands
of stairs.
And the strangest one of these is the Ascensore
Castello d'Albertis Montegalleto.
Or: the castle elevator.
Years ago, you'd have to walk through 300m
of tunnel yourself to reach the lift,
but now, if you start at the bottom,
an odd little square box comes to pick you
up.
It looks a bit like a regular elevator car,
only going horizontally.
You get on, it takes you the 300 metres through
the rock,
past some control equipment and then,
after a bit of shunting around with another
box that's headed the other way...
It goes vertically,
right up to the castle at the top of the hill.
Now you might think, that's a great idea in
theory,
it's like a Star Trek turbolift, but surely
that's dangerous?
And I say that wearing a red shirt.
Elevators need to have all sorts of protection
systems
so one bad cable can't snap and cause disaster.
How can they possibly make one that has all
that protection
when it's got to detach itself and move off?
The answer is: they can't. Because that's
not what it's doing.
And in hindsight, the solution is kind of
obvious:
there are two separate systems here.
It's the same hack that Disney use for the
Tower of Terror at their theme parks:
the bit that the passengers get into can only
go horizontally on its own.
It attaches to a cable that pulls it along.
When it reaches the lift shaft,
it's actually getting into another, bigger
elevator,
it attaches itself firmly to that,
and then it gets hoisted up and down in safety
as if it were a regular passenger elevator.
It's a brilliant bit of engineering.
And it's all so people don't have to walk
300 metres to a regular lift.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here!]